[Aplausos]
[Música]
brasil es el país del futuro y parece
que lo seguirá siendo para siempre
últimamente se habla mucho de los
escándalos de corrupción en este país de
la crisis por la que está pasando o de
la violencia urbana en muchas ciudades
como río de janeiro pero hay otro
aspecto muy característico de brasil del
que no se suele hablar tanto en los
medios de comunicación hablamos del país
más caro de toda latinoamérica
[Música]
tal cual como lo oís si queréis iros de
compras en una ciudad como sao paulo o
río de janeiro ya podéis ir preparando
la cartera porque os puede salir tan
caro como nueva york o londres incluso
los propios brasileños tienen una
palabra para esto lo llaman el justo
brasil algo así como un sobrecoste que
hay que pagar por el mero hecho de vivir
en el país de la samba y los carnavales
[Música]
vamos a tomar como ejemplo la
hamburguesa big mac que nos tomamos en
un mcdonald's los que lleváis tiempo
suscritos a visual político ya sabéis
que el llamado índice big mac se utiliza
en economía como precio de referencia
para medir el coste de vida de un país
un bigmac es un bigmac pero lo llaman
por ejemplo en suiza que es uno de los
países más ricos del mundo el 'big mac'
nos costaría el equivalente a 675
dólares sin embargo en perú que es un
país más pobre nos saldría por 3 con 23
dólares tiene lógica verdad a fin de
cuentas el sueldo medio que cobra un
suizo es muy superior al de un peruano
[Música]
pues bien en brasil este bigmac nos
costaría cinco con diez dólares es decir
es mucho más caro que otros países como
reino unido canadá o dinamarca según la
web ex patishtán puntocom
sao paulo es la ciudad más cara de toda
américa del sur con unos precios muy
parecidos a los de otras ciudades como
houston en eeuu o berlín en alemania
[Música]
y os preguntaréis cuánto ganan los
brasileños para poderse permitir este
coste de vida son más ricos que los
colombianos o los chilenos lo cierto es
que no el salario medio en brasil no
llega a los 600 dólares mensuales sin ir
más lejos los argentinos o los chilenos
tienen sueldos más generosos así que la
pregunta es por qué brasil es tan caro
cuáles son las razones que explican que
un país de renta media tenga unos
precios de país rico hoy vamos a
responder a esta pregunta y creedme esto
explica en buena medida muchos de los
problemas que han llevado a brasil a la
crisis que está sufriendo estos días
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
una economía aislada del exterior muchos
pensaréis que brasil es un país abierto
al comercio internacional verdad
a fin de cuentas muchas empresas
internacionales como el banco santander
o telefónica tienen presencia en este
país desde hace años sin embargo brasil
tiene los aranceles más altos de toda
latinoamérica y esto qué significa pues
bien imaginad que tenemos una empresa
que fabrica teléfonos móviles en eeuu y
queremos vender en el mercado brasileño
pues bien por el mero hecho de vender un
producto hecho en otro país tenemos que
pagar un impuesto especial que puede
superar el 35 por ciento del precio de
mercado y como os podéis imaginar este
tipo de políticas tienen consecuencias
muy claras para los ciudadanos
[Música]
no sé en marcha del mercado brasileño
debido a los altos aranceles tal cual
como lo es durante varios años los
brasileños que querían comprarse una wii
o una nintendo ds tenían que viajar a
uruguay para encontrarla curiosamente
esto supuso una ventaja fenomenal para
sus competidores sobre todo microsoft y
su xbox sabéis por qué pues porque
microsoft tiene una planta en brasil
donde fabrica la xbox one es decir que
no la tiene que importar
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estáis pensando que poner
aranceles altos está muy bien porque
obliga a las empresas extranjeras a
poner fábricas en el país y dar trabajo
a los ciudadanos verdad pues realmente
no es así
pensadlo bien cuando microsoft monta una
fábrica en brasil necesita importar las
máquinas con las que se ensamblan los
componentes se cortan los plásticos
etcétera y muchas de esas máquinas
vienen de otros países lo que significa
que tienen que pagar un impuesto
especial y al final son mucho más caras
que si la fábrica estuviera en otro país
con menos aranceles
[Música]
y quien paga ese sobrecosto
efectivamente el consumidor final eso
explica que incluso muchos productos
fabricados en brasil como por ejemplo
algunos modelos de volkswagen sean
extremadamente caros
para que os hagáis una idea si compráis
un volkswagen golf en ciudad de méxico
os costaría unos 15.000 dólares de eeuu
mientras que en sao paulo tendríais que
apoquinar más de 25 mil y todo esto pese
a que este modelo de coche concretamente
está fabricado en las afueras del mismo
sao paulo
pero espera de un momento porque esta no
es la única razón que explica este gusto
brasil
[Música]
el gusto logístico imaginad un
agricultor que cultiva soja en el estado
de pará al norte del país si quiere
transportar un cargamento para venderlo
en sao paulo debería enviarlo en un
camión y pasar por la autopista
br 163 pues bien de los 1000 kilómetros
que tiene esta carretera 100 no tienen
ni siquiera alquitrán basta con que un
día llueva para que los camiones no
puedan pasar o se queden hundidos en el
fango pero éste sólo es un ejemplo más
lo cierto es que brasil tiene una de las
peores infraestructuras del mundo
incluso un país como la india tiene
mejores carreteras para que os hagáis
una idea cada vez que una agricultura
estadounidense bien de 100 dólares de
soja se tiene que gastar 9 en costes de
transporte ese mismo agricultor en
brasil tendría que gastarse 25 dólares y
a falta de carreteras
los brasileños invierten en camiones que
a menudo se estropean y encarecen aún
más los costes
[Música]
lógicamente todo esto también se traduce
en precios más altos para todos los
bienes que se venden en brasil y os
preguntaréis por qué el gobierno de
brasil no invierte en infraestructuras a
fin de cuentas tienen empresas punteras
como el grupo odebrecht seguro que todos
los que veáis este vídeo desde
latinoamérica os sonará el nombre
odebrecht era la empresa de
construcciones y de ingeniería más
grande de toda la región
y digo era porque después de
protagonizar el mayor escándalo de
corrupción de la historia de todo el
continente es difícil saber lo que va a
pasar con esta empresa y esto explica en
parte porque brasil tiene unas
infraestructuras tan cochambrosas a fin
de cuentas buena parte del dinero se va
en sobornos y tráfico de influencias
pero no sólo eso cuál fue la brillante
idea del gobierno de brasil para
modernizar su país
efectivamente juegos olímpicos y
mundiales de fútbol
hoy en día las grandes ciudades
brasileñas tienen unos preciosos
estadios con luces y tecnología puntera
sin embargo fuera de esas metrópolis nos
encontramos con ferrocarriles
abandonados autopistas sin asfaltar o
incluso barrios enteros que no tienen
una simple línea de autobús que les
conecte con la ciudad
las infraestructuras lamentables de
brasil cuestan a la economía nacional
más de 48 mil millones de dólares cada
año por supuesto que esto no solo tiene
consecuencias en los precios que pagan
los brasileños sino también en los que
pagamos en el resto del mundo por los
productos que se fabrican en brasil pero
de eso hablaremos en otro vídeo porque
ahora la pregunta que os estaréis
haciendo es como alguien que gana menos
de 600 dólares al mes se puede gastar 25
en comerse una pizza normal en un
restaurante de sao paulo ahora lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
y enganchados al crédito durante décadas
brasil tenía una de las inflaciones más
altas del mundo en los años 80 y 90
llegaron a superar el 6 mil por ciento
de tasa de inflación interanual para que
os hagáis una idea imaginad que en 1980
os tomáis una cerveza en un bar de río
de janeiro que esa cerveza os cuesta
vamos a decir 100 cruceros el crucero
era la divisa que usaban en aquella
época pues bien un año más tarde en el
mismo bar esa misma cerveza os costaría
600 mil cruceros
como os podéis imaginar esa
hiperinflación creó unos hábitos de
consumo muy distintos a los que tenemos
en el resto del mundo para sobrevivir
las tiendas brasileñas se acostumbraron
a vender productos a plazos y estas
estrategias continúan siendo muy útiles
en un país con unos precios tan altos
por eso todavía hoy podemos ver los
precios de las tiendas con un numerito
al lado que puede decir por 10 por 12
por 20 ese número y esa equis significa
que puedes pagar ese producto en 10 12 ó
20 plazos dicho de otra forma la
pregunta que se hacen muchos brasileños
no es si este traje o esta televisión es
cara o barata sino si podré pagar los
plazos en los próximos dos años y como
os podéis imaginar cuando pagas algo a
plazos te sale mucho más caro por
ejemplo aquí tenemos un smartphone en un
ecommerce brasileño
si os fijáis pagándolo de una sola vez
nos cuesta 632 reales que serían como
unos 200 dólares
sin embargo pagando lo a plazos nos
costaría el equivalente a 217 dólares un
7% de diferencia que se suma al resto de
sobrecostes de los que hemos hablado ya
todo esto significa que el brasileño
medio está continuamente pagando deudas
y lógicamente esto tiene sus
consecuencias
cerca del 60% de los brasileños está en
deudas por los pagos aplazados pero
esperad un momento porque esto no es lo
peor de todo en los últimos años ha
aparecido un nuevo elemento que ha
elevado este costo brasil a unas cotas
verdaderamente nacho vidal ya nas
[Música]
en las tarjetas de crédito a principios
de los años 2000 brasil se convirtió en
la niña bonita de todos los bancos
grandes entidades como el santander o
credit suisse dispararon sus inversiones
en el país hablamos de un mercado con
más de 200 millones de habitantes que
estaba en pleno crecimiento y donde los
precios son altos y la población está
acostumbrada a consumir cosas pagando
las a plazos
en otras palabras brasil era el lugar
perfecto para vender tarjetas de crédito
pues de óscar es de 2005 el mercado de
tarjetas de crédito en brasil ha crecido
más de un 20% cada año en el año 2012
los brasileños ya tenían una media de 2
tarjetas de crédito por persona y las
usaban como si no existiera mañana
brasil era el país que más dinero gasta
va en crédito per cápita de toda
latinoamérica sin embargo estas alegrías
durarían bastante poco en el año 2012
saltaron las alarmas en todos los bancos
del país
la morosidad en las tarjetas de crédito
de brasil alcanza un 27 por ciento en
abril de 2012 en un país en crisis donde
el desempleo crece y los sueldos bajan
es muy difícil devolver las deudas y qué
pasa cuando un banco tiene miedo de los
morosos
efectivamente suben los tipos de interés
[Música]
los brasileños tienen que pagar un
interés de 414 por ciento en sus
tarjetas de crédito imaginad que
utilizamos la tarjeta para comprar una
televisión que cuesta 1000 dólares y la
pagamos en 12 platos mensuales pues bien
al final del año sumando los intereses
la televisión nos habría costado cinco
mil dólares no está mal verdad y ojo que
no se nos olvide que el salario medio en
brasil ni siquiera llega a los 600
dólares al mes
en otras palabras que por muchas medidas
que se pongan para luchar contra la
pobreza la mayoría de los brasileños
viven en condiciones de subsistencia y
lo que es peor apenas pueden ahorrar
dinero con lo que se pierde en el
trabajo no tienen un colchón para poder
sobrevivir y eso explica noticias como
esta
de hecho en río de janeiro aumentan en
un 150 por ciento en sólo tres años
mientras tanto el presidente de brasil
michel temer está acusado por cargos de
corrupción y tiene la popularidad por
los suelos y por supuesto los anteriores
presidentes están igual o peor
si queréis conocer algo más sobre ese
escándalo de brecht que ha sumido a
brasil en el caos político
haced clic en este vídeo y ahora la
pregunta es puede brasil salir de esta
situación
quién puede reformar el país podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios como siempre no olvidéis que
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribiros al canal para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones
si os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like
y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]